and i'm listening to this song and then  i go play it for dylan and i tell dylan  i said dylan you know there are certain  gifts god gives you that's not yours  it's the world this is what do you mean  i said if you got a great voice you got  to share it with the world you can't  just keep it to yourself you got to  share with the world if you are somebody  that's a leader  and somebody that's got strong values  and principles  we probably need more men like you to  raise kids because you would raise  better  kids in a society like this where not  only would the world benefit from it  your last name would benefit from it  your heritage would benefit from it  they're just that's the processing for  me with kids there are certain men that  i'll say dude don't have kids  just go ahead bro stay single the rest  your life but certain people you're like  look those values being duplicated  amongst one two three four other people  i wonder what the world would be with  you having more kids